JENSEN.
THE CAPS WORK THROUGH CENTER.
SPRONG TRIESBACKSTROM, ON THROU
MANTHA.
WASHINGTON GETTING ACTIVE  ANDT.
BROCK NELSON, ALWAYS DANGEROUS
FOR NEW CHANGE.
BEAUVILLIEIE
ON THIS PLAY.
HE RICOCHETS THAT TO THE N COME
OVER, GET ON THE HEADSET WITH
THE SITUU SAY IT
ISN'T.
TO ME, HE GOT HIS STICK UNDER
THE LEFT DISTRIBUTES.
PELECH FAKES AND FIRES.
THAT'S BROKEN UP IN FRONT.
GREAT FORTUNE IN THE GAME ONZON
THE DELIBERATIONS IS THROUGH.
WE'RE  HIS
FORMER TEAMMATE, VARLAMOV'S  ALT
AROUND THE D.  EARLIER IN
THE CAMPAIGN.
ORLOV, FIVE ON DEFENSE.
THAT WAS A TWO-ON-ONE, AND
CALLSCORES!
THE GREAT 8 EXPRESS EVEN MOVING
IT'S'SNEW YORK.
BIG IT WAS
WINNER BACK ON FRIDAY IN
VANCOUVER.
WILSON, KUZNETSOV, CARLSON TWO-K
IN O.T.
3-3  AND HE'LL
GIVE THE ISLANDER A LITTLEOF THE
WEBBING THAT CATCHES IT ENOUGH
JUST LETS IT GO. THAT PLAY,
NOTICE
>> Craig: EVERYTHING IS FINDINH
THE CATCHING MITT.
>>